and what our goal is is to solve for
what X is but the way that we do that is
we try to isolate or get the radical by
itself so what I'm going to do is I'm
gonna try to get the square root of x
plus 1 by itself by working from the
outside in and doing the opposite
operation so I'm going to add 2 to both
sides okay to keep the equation balanced
so that gives us 2 squared of X plus 1
equals 8 I want to do the opposite of
multiplying by 2 I'm going to divide
both sides of the equation by 2 so now
we're left with square root of x plus 1
equals 4 ok now what we're gonna do is
we're going to get rid of this radical
this square root by doing the opposite
and that's 2 square ok both sides the
square and the square root those cancel
one another out we get X plus 1 equals
16 and if we subtract 1 from both sides
we get x equals 15 now when you work
with radical equations sometimes you get
what are called extraneous solutions
extraneous roots false answers however
you want to say it but what you want to
do to make sure that this is actually
the correct answer is to take 15 go
ahead and put it back into the original
equation and make sure that it works
because sometimes like I said you do get
this false answer so you have to check
your answer so just make sure so this is
going to be 15 plus 1 okay minus 2
equals 6 so this is 16 square root of 16
is going to give us 4 so that's 2 times
4 and that's going to be 8 minus 2 and
you can see 6 equals 6 so yeah 15 is
indeed the correct answer sometimes what
will happen if this didn't work you
would just say there's no solution
sometimes when you solve these equations
you get two answers and maybe one works
and one dozen or maybe they both don't
work or maybe they both do work but
again you just want to double check them
in the original equation okay let's look
at an example B here here you can see
this doesn't look like a radical
equation like the original one that we
did but it isn't in fact a radical
because if you see this denominator
that's really representing the cube root
of AX the quantity squared okay but what
we're gonna do is we're just going to
work from the outside in towards this
variable by doing the inverse or
opposite operation so we've got 3 X to
the 2/3 minus 2 equals 10 I'm going to
add 2 to both sides okay and then we've
got 3 X to the 2/3 equals 12 I'm going
to divide by 3 okay because I'm trying
to get that variable by itself we've got
X
the two thirds equals four and then what
I'm going to do now is I'm going to
raise both sides to the reciprocal power
so instead of the two-thirds power I'm
going to raise it to the three halves
power like this and you can see when you
have a power to power you multiply it so
this is just going to give you X to the
first which is what we wanted it to just
X by itself but remember the denominator
is the root so this is saying the square
root of four the numerator is the power
so that's raised to the third power
square root of 4 is 2 and then 2 cubed
is 2 times 2 times 2 which is 8 so E is
going to be the answer to this problem
but again let's just go ahead and put it
back into the double check this is the
cube root of 8 which is 2 2 squared is 4
times 3 is 12 minus 2 is 10 so just
remember the denominator is the root and
the numerator is the power so this has
been how to work with radical equations
how to solve them I'm gonna have another
video getting into some more challenging
ones and so you can check out that if
you're interested subscribe to the
channel check out more math tutoring
videos on my youtube channel
Myra's math tutoring and I look forward
to seeing the future videos